[Music]
hello dear friends of Sam TV we are
delighted to come to you with this
program of i' like to know the program
that allows us to answer the questions
you send helps us to interact to get to
know you a little better and we thank
you for continuing to send your
questions to our uh address to our uh
Direction here in the studio we want to
remind you you can send your questions
to TVs tv.org and remember that we have
this pledge to you that we will answer
the questions uh thoroughly Through the
Bible and we pray that we can answer
them as soon as we get to them I am with
Pastor CA Murray pastor what a blessing
to have you here with me and to share
and study and reply to the questions
that our friends have sent it's always
good to study the word of God with you
Pastor David and um this pleasure this
program rather is a pleasure and of
course studying the word of God is a is
a double blessing amen for that and we
want to dive into the questions uh we
want to start but before we do this I
would like to ask you Pastor CA if you
can actually pray for us and then read
the first question for us okay father
God again we thank you and praise you
for this opportunity to study the word
of God for we know that contact with
your holy word makes us stronger in the
Lord gives us information and
inspiration and gives us what we need to
do to follow you to be like you and to
be ready for the day when you come back
to take us home and so Lord we thank you
we ask you to bless these questions
bless these answers May they be your
words and your thoughts for your people
amen bless us use us so that we may be a
blessing to them and we thank you in
Jesus name amen amen amen Pastor David
as you well know this question is a
continuation from last right program uh
brother Grayson from Tanzania I don't
know if it's Tanzania or Tanzania I
always say Tanzania I hope that's
correct uh Africa he had three questions
and we answered one before we concluded
our last program so you want to pick up
our question number two today all right
he's talking talking about and of course
this was addressed to Pastor bore so we
will answer it in his stad in his
absence uh he says 24 Elders are
representatives of unfallen
Worlds the question is are the habitants
of th habitants of those worlds are
human or Angels that's the first
question then he's got a subset of
questions are they human beings
represented by strong angels and
Heavenly councils or are they humans but
they are promoted by God so that they
are called Angels so we've got this this
Triplex of questions to deal with and we
can work our way through them I need to
say this to you my pastor my friend yeah
um the identity of the 24
Elders pracon is not going to keep
anybody out of the Kingdom correct this
is one of those those questions which
are important to us who study the word
of God yeah but if you never got to the
24 Elders you can still get into the
kingdom you know want you to know and
understand that but for those who are uh
maybe a little more advanced in their
study and and don't like to have things
dangling out there for which there's no
answer this is important to many many
people correct and a number of people
have put study and time and energy in
that so the 24 Elders are
representatives of unfallen Worlds that
is true yes we need to know are they
humans or are they Angels therein lies
the question you want to launch out or
yeah absolutely I can try to launch some
of the questions okay the first uh I
suppose the first question that I would
like to address is actually the you know
the the the explanation are these
individuals the 24 Elders are they
humans or are they Angels uh I would
like to start with that question first
because I believe that it will really
helps us to see then the rest of the
answer so the first thing is for example
in Revelation chapter 5 and we have uh
you know the introduction actually in
chapter four but chapter five we
actually continue with the uh Narrative
of what the 24 Elders are doing in
heaven and in verse
four uh I want to notice that John as
he's contemplating this scene that he's
being this Vision that he's taken upon
he says there and I wept much because no
man was found worthy to open and to read
the book neither to look there on this
is where he actually sees the book that
could not be opened that was had Seven
Seals and nobody could open in heaven
and so as we're seeing this uh then
verse five notice what it says there and
one of the elders this is the one of the
24 Elders mentioned right in the earlier
in the in the chapter says one of the
elders said unto me weep not behold PA
the lion of the tribe of Judah the root
of David had prevailed to open the book
and to lose the Seven Seals thereof so
the one of the elders one of the 24
Elders is the one that gives this uh
words of affirmation of of comfort to
John that they have found somebody
worthy to open the book yes and
so let me now go to the spirit of
Prophecy in the
uh in the manuscript release number 12
page
291 we actually have and I'm going to
read it from the spirit prophecy here we
actually have this that the servant of
the Lord
says there is there in his open hand lay
the
book uh rather I'm sorry this is I'm
reading the wrong paragraph is the next
paragraph This role was written within
and without
John says I wept much because no man was
found worthy to open and read the book
neither to look there on the vision as
presented to John made its impression
upon his mind the destiny of every
nation was contained in that book John
was stressed at the otter inability of
any human being or Angelic intelligence
to read the words or even to look there
on his soul was rough up to such a point
of agony and suspense that one of the
strong Angels had compassion on him and
laying his hand on him assuredly said
weep not Behold The Lion of the tribe of
Judah the root of David had prevailed to
open the book and to lose the Seven
Seals thereof so here we actually see
that El white indicates that as John was
expressing this weeping and this
Agony the Bible says one of the elders
El says one of the strong Angels yes
comes to him so these Elders from this
prayer prophecy we can see that it's an
angel a strong Angel and uh I I do
incline to believe that these are
definitely this the the the concept of
these angels there there are strong
Angels there are representatives of of
the unfallen worlds that go before the
Lord so I would not consider them humans
they are actually angels and I want to
put a hit the pause button right there
because you you've hit on a very
important point yeah uh the fact is they
can only be one of two things yes humans
redeemed from the earth or angels we
know now that the term Elder can we can
substitute the term angel so that means
that those that are relying on hum the
word Elder as have to be humans in all
points in all cases and all times that's
a false assumption right because here we
see Angel is substituted for elders so
that sort of plays a little bit with the
idea that they must come from the earth
because of the word Elders well the
Elder the word Elder is not
interchangeable with with the word the
word Angel um and he's asking the
questions are they are are they strong
angels in in these councils so we've
opened a door to say that they could be
indeed Angels right okay do you have
anything else you want to add in there
well this you know we know that from the
story of job that there were the sons of
God are coming before him you know and
this is is a a council a a government
Council if you will of the universe come
before the Lord so uh this is an explan
uh when we look to the in the job story
and the explanation or the the Bible
gives us to how the even Satan came
representing the Earth we notice that he
comes as the one that claims the Earth
as his and he as an angel represents the
Earth so I will say that the other
Elders connecting to this understanding
that the spirit prophecy con says that
is a strong angel I will say that this
is is further evidence to show that
these are indeed the 24 Elders are
indeed Angels but the last thing that he
has a question on is whether or not the
the in the unfallen worlds there are
other humans or not and so I you know
cuz you could say well are the elders
angels and then are there other humans
on other worlds uh just like like here
it was Satan Lucifer the representative
of this Earth as as the angel if you
will but I think that in this scenario
in this situation uh the Bible sort of
explains that men was created a little
lower than the angels we know that from
Psalms and we also know that the the
plan of of of the Earth the plan of
creation of man was a very unique plan
was was kind of a exclusive plan if you
will this is what was has been revealed
to us so uh we don't necessarily and and
and you know we have never seen any
evidence that there are actually other
humans other human beings on other
places of the world in other other um
worlds if you will um there is from the
spirit prophecy we know that when she
has seen those other beings she doesn't
say they're humans there's never any
indication that she says oh I saw
another humans there yeah that's another
excuse me good point a very strong point
I I believe have always believed that
there's other life on other planets but
the term humans is kind of reserved for
the inhabitants of this world yes you
know so when you when you say are there
other people just like us on other
planets then the Bible does not support
that it does support that are other life
forms other intelligences uh on other
world and of course angels are are on
other places but they are not humans
they are different kind of of of life
form so to answer that last question as
he's asking it but were they promoted by
God and called angels that idea is not
supported in the Bible at all there's
there's nothing that supports that idea
of any kind of promotions humans will
always be human yeah you know they'll
always be human throughout all eternity
uh and Christ identifies with humans uh
by taking a a shape that will last to
Eternity and of course carrying the
wounds in his hands inside through all
eternity so there is no graduation from
Human to angelhood that's not supported
by the word of God no I mean the Lord
and I maybe this is where our our friend
Grayson may have been a little bit
questioning because I mean the Lord does
say in Matthew 22 when he speaks to the
Sadducees about Resurrection in verse 30
you know that in uh in the resurrection
we are not going to be married and in
that sense we are as the angels in God
in heaven in in that sense in that sense
in that sense but it's not saying that
we're going to be converted into Angels
if you will or we're going to stop being
humans and become Angels it's just
basically saying that that aspect the
Lord has refrained you know according to
the Bible that he we're not going to
have that aspect of marriage or giving
in marriage and and sometimes some
people have a question about that and
you know they they start thinking no
we're we're not going to have marriage
the truth of the matter is that Christ
mentions that and we have to accept that
as as as as a fact you know so how will
the Lord will solve these issues you
know why he does that he will not give
us or take away from us something that
will hinder our happiness yes and we
have to just trust in the Lord but this
does not necessarily mean that we are
going to be or actually it's not
implying that we're going to be
transformed into Angels we're just not
going to have like the Angels we're not
going to have that experience and that's
another point that I think also helps us
to understand that in the other worlds
the and you know the holy beings that
are in the worlds may have life forms
they are they're they are like Angels
but they are not necessarily humans as
we are I I I like your your explanation
there particularly because it's you
cannot use Matthew 22 as a as a
prescription for for Doctrine because
Christ was trying to clear up a problem
exactly the the the Sadducees came to
him in verse 23 of that of that same
chapter if I recall the verse says that
they didn't even believe in Resurrection
so they're just trying to put up
something to try to trick Christ Christ
to get him in into some hot water so
they they made this scenario and of
course it was something they were trying
to sell that they didn't even buy
themselves so Christ tells them first of
all you Heir yeah you're doing wrong
because you don't know the scriptures
and you don't know the power of exactly
so let me clean this mess up for you you
know so you can understand uh so to take
that which was which was sort of uh an
apologetic by Jesus and try to make a
whole doctrinal premise out of that is
does violence to the scriptures I
believe so I I think uh We've handled
that well um the the idea that they
cannot be um from the earth and they are
powerful angels from other worlds this
ministry has a very strong in fact I I
downloaded it just a little bit very
strong um apologetic on this particular
question and you can download it myself
yourself I just popped it in here a
minute ago and um so you can you can
look at it and thoroughly familiarize
yourself with what what uh what is being
said and it's good stuff let's go to the
last and we're going to do we're going
to do one question on this show um the
last of three is it a sin for women to
braid hair without using ornaments or
artificial
or artificial materials I know he's
coming from right first Peter and 1
Timothy which talks about braided
hair the the issue that's being dealt
with in First Peter and First Timothy is
is a Roman or midle Eastern custom of
braiding with three strands mhm and many
times using ornamental silver or gold as
that third strand so as you braid the
hair as you braid it you've got hair
hair gold hair hair gold hair hair gold
so you get this this this look which is
very ostentatious very showy and of
course uh that's what he's he's uh envey
against to have braided hair per se is
not uh uh a sin in fact uh if you look
at many pictures of Ellen White she had
braids she had braids and and and they
brought the braids across the top you
know if you had a long enough hair to do
that so that was very common for for
that was considered modest it was
considered in fact back in in those days
having your hair Dro down to your
shoulders was a little that yeah was a
little loose so you you go with Customs
what braided hair per se is is not in my
mind uh any sin against God absolutely
pastor and the you know the important
Point as you well mentioned is that they
were creating this this place in their
hair to first of all is ostentatious was
drawing attention to themselves more
than necessary um and it was vain it was
a it's a it's a vanity you know it's
just like trying to you know put like
you know instead of buying a simple suit
you know you're going to buy these
expensive suits today and just to you
know to write them to yourself so the
Bible is very clear in the sense that
it's it recommendations not to appear
like the hidden like the world another
thing is that the it was very common in
those days that harlots actually would
use those you know gold and silver in
their hair to draw again attention to
their profession and to men towards them
so it the Apostle is giving them
instructions just like we actually had
in the Book of Leviticus when it spoke
about men not you know trimming their
beers and their hair it was again
because the Lord didn't want his people
to be confused or to look like the world
or to look like somebody that they're
not supposed to you know to to appear us
you examp you give an example in another
previous presentation we had where today
if you use uh rainbow for example you
know nothing the rainbow is a beautiful
element but because of the connotation
that has been used today which actually
is the wrong rainbow they actually use
six colors not seven like Bible but you
know but still nobody's going to count
them but if you go with the rainbow you
know and you don't you're not careful
you're bringing the wrong idea perhaps
instead of helping them so even today
maybe that's one of the things you would
have to avoid just to not present
yourself in a way that may d ract or
send the wrong message to someone else
the the the overriding biblical
principle is Modesty yes um back in in
the the uh 1900s uh during the days of
Ellen White they had a problem with the
American costume a big issue you know um
should the the the skirt come down to
the ground if it should it come just
above the knee of course above the ankle
rather not the knee because today it's
the knee back then it was the ankle
above the ankle so what we have to do is
look at what societ is doing and and not
not lead in fashion years ago we went to
this uh a couple of church people took
me to this um very expensive men's store
in Woodbury commins New York and we went
in and um I I tried on a jacket and and
the guy said well that that Sports code
is
$2,700 so I took it off very
gently I said no I love I'm fine thank
you very much I said let's get out of
the store I can't do anything so Ellen
White says this Pastor David she says
buy the best you can afford yes don't
always buy the cheapest because that's
not that's not wise nor is a good
stewardship but don't go into Hawk don't
go into debt uh trying to impress other
other people and make sure your clothes
is modest our modest when you're coming
down the street the first thing that
people shouldn't say is oh look at
Pastor David you know kind of
to my friend used to tell me you know no
that's not that's not what they want to
see is your character your love for the
Lord those kinds of things but but not
always and and and today in our society
we lead with dress that's the most
important thing how you dress how you
dress how you dress uh and and I think
your point is very very well taken
modesty is the the the watch word for
the Christian amen amen for that now uh
we have one question and I think that's
important one more question we can
answer uh to our friend Henry and the
question is this uh I am told that
whether I accept or reject the
investigative judgment that is affect
that it affects in no way my salvation
so let me put this again I am told that
what whether I accept or reject
investigative judgment that it affects
in no way my salvation what say you is
investigation judge investigative
judgment an irrelevant message in
respect toward our salvation and um you
know I think pastor this question is one
that I I feel for my friend or friend
Henry here who is being told these
things because let's just put it this
way if we go to the Book of Revelation
chapter 14: 6 MH through 13 we have the
Three Angels messages yes the messages
that are to be preached for
today the first message starts with the
word and the expression that we are to
fear God for the hour of judgment has
come yes now if you have no knowledge of
the judgment
no knowledge you know you are just
reading the Bible and you just learned
the love of the Lord and whatnot yeah
for you whether or not you understand or
not the investigative judgment it
doesn't really necessarily affect you
yes as long as there's a real connection
and a living faith growing in Christ
well said but for you today if I receive
the light of the judgment and I said you
know what it doesn't really matter what
I do or I mean accepting or not you are
rejecting light and my worry or my
concern would be that somebody that says
that and rejects light is a danger you
know why do you want to reject that
light of the Judgment yes for what
reason that's the danger so that would
be the question it's like if you want to
reject the light of the Judgment because
you just don't agree with it and you can
live a life without you know repentance
or without moving towards the Lord
working with Christ then it it won't you
know it won't make a difference whether
or not you accept it or not because
you're really trying to do a life of
reject or Rebellion against the Lord yes
but if you are with the Lord and you
hear the Judgment for you since Christ
is your Advocate and the judge in the
Judgment for you is a blessing you are
hidden in Christ there's nothing to be
worried about as long as you remain in
Christ amen a couple of things come to
my mind one
the third Three Angels
messages um are it's like the that
little Arm coming down and the lights on
the train track yes it's ding ding ding
ding ding ding you know it's it's it's
telling you get your head up cuz
something is coming and you need to be
aware of that absolutely so if you
really love Christ why would you reject
a message which tells you the hour is
late which tells you what's going on in
heaven which tells you that your case is
being decided and which tells you that
sooner or later this thing is going to
end and it's going to be sooner than
later exactly so you've got all of these
things so to say it in no way affects
your salvation that's wrong because it
does affect your salvation whether you
know it or not exactly and if you're
neglecting or rejecting this because
just don't want to follow the lord then
the three in those messages is not your
problem yeah you you've got a bigger
problem and that bigger problem is your
relationship with Christ you're being in
Rebellion you're not following him
you're not following a it's like a stop
sign at the end of the street you are
running the stop sign you're going to
get killed man you know you're
something's going to happen that's going
to be bad for you abolutely so the ey
that it no way in affects you I can't I
can't buy that I can't accept that
because it does affect you whether you
know it or not and I you know and that's
that's I'm saying I think that you got
to be very careful who you listen to who
is telling you these things you know I I
I believe that is important that we
listen to to to you know to people who
are speaking according to the light and
to the testimony of the word of God if
we don't see people speaking to the
light we they know to the truth to the
to the to the that said the lord it's
best we don't listen to those
individuals cuz at the end of the day
they're trying to deceive and the enemy
says I mean the well Bible speaks that
in the last days many people will come
professing to be you know Godly but
they're going to deny the power of God
yes and that's going to be a problem so
yes yes that that last line is it
irrelevant um a lot of Adventists have
gone to Mission fields and done some
pretty tough things for the Lord because
it is very very relevant it is key to
our Salvation again uh it's something
that's very very important so Pastor
well thank you for watching and we look
forward to seeing you next time here and
i' like to know may God bless you
[Music]